the casting director you already knew
her is that how she was
we did not know um we did not know him
i'm so sorry multiple him multiple hymns
triple him
bad host our dear friend loved the
script
and she was really excited about it and
she was working for
uh barton's knee casting and took it to
rich dahlia who um
got really excited about it too dillian
adelia i always thought it was dahlia
delia
so yeah so they um they really loved it
they wanted to take it on and we were
totally thrilled so we kind of sent them
it was definitely a back and forth we
had our list
of you know actors that we really wanted
to work with and
they were like yes yes no no yes
here are some other ideas you might not
be able to get this person but what
about this person
um and you know we made offers to people
and then
um once we had made offers to people we
started auditioning people
um it was kind of concurrent we had
offers out to people but then we were
also auditioning people at the same time
um which is you do that as a backup
you're not like
you don't the the part basically this is
really actually a good tip if you do get
in a position
where you have the opportunity to work
with a really good casting director
suddenly your pre-production schedule
becomes this
if if you've decided when you're going
to shoot the movie which i think is a
great thing to do i think it's good to
say
we're shooting this movie now we'd like
you to be in it and sure you have to
move a couple weeks due to scheduling or
whatnot but
the problem that you're going to run
into is suddenly like how long do you
leave an offer out there
right what happens some people are going
to not you won't hear from them for
a week and a half because they haven't
had time to read it because they're on
set and they read it and they love and
they want to be on it and other people
you haven't heard them
for a week and a half because they're
just never going to read it and they're
not
no one's going to get back to you same
scenario no rep is going to call you
nothing's going to happen so
we have that experience both experience
yeah it's a constant like back and forth
dance of like
trying to back channel with agents and
like
are is this a possibility is it worth us
leaving this offer out there or is it
you know a fool's errand and we should
move on
so it's because it's a very interesting
it's a dance
dance yeah it's a real dance that you're
doing where you
are making some offers and then
auditioning and then
it's yeah it's it gets kind of
complicated waiting and then maybe
auditioning more
and if you know trying to fill in the
gaps once you have
put people together then trying to
figure out like rejiggering
the whole thing yeah just because the
ensemble was so
important obviously it's an ensemble
piece so and it was vital that
you believe that these people would all
be friends which you know we had some
really wonderful people that we
loved and that we so wanted to cast but
they just felt like
a little bit younger than everyone else
or a little bit older just not
believable
as friends or not believable as a couple
um yeah but yeah i think we got lucky
yeah well forgive me for dehumanizing
these actors but is it almost like a
real estate offer like you have there's
like a contingency period and you're
like
you know what i know we're gonna pull
this i mean i wish it was like that
because when you're doing real estate
both people are communicating right like
someone makes an offer and then you make
a counteroffer
like this is more like an abusive high
school relationship where like
you facebook someone and you like did
they get it are they gonna email back
are they not we don't know
it's a lot of just like i mean we had
there were uh
probably one or two offers that we put
out we still have no idea if the people
ever
got the script or read it or didn't or
anything we just kind of pull
you just call and say okay we're pulling
the offer and often
agents don't want their clients to do
these movies because these movies are
no money they have the potential to be
helpful like i think sometimes an actor
has a better sense of what will help
their career than their agent does
because their agent is thinking
in a very specific kind of marketable
way like
in terms of market share like they're
doing this which can get us this which
can get us here
and then they're making a lot of money
and they're on a tv show or they you
know have this they have the second lead
and big movie and it becomes the first
lead but
sometimes actors know that they have
abilities that an agent has no idea
about or doesn't care about it
they wanted they want to get out of the
hole that they have been put in
you know or the you know the type cast
but i think sometimes they could they
know how to help their career better
than the agent does like they they're
like i'm good at this and nobody knows
it
so i'm gonna take ownership of my career
and go out and do a movie that shows how
well i can do this or yeah sometimes
they just wanna do it
they're like i don't i don't wanna i
wanna spend three weeks doing something
that's fun for me and that's different
and even if it's not gonna
you know catapult me into fame it's what
i wanna do
and i think that if you can get to
people on those terms
you have a much better chance of casting
them but often their representation is
like a roadblock
versus yeah a a help and
often that's the only way to get
something to people is your cast
investor sends it to their agent and
that's it
but it's nice when you can have a
casting director who like really knows
the people and can just call them yeah
yeah and
we got in trouble with one actor because
the casting director had a personal
relationship with them and just sent
them the script and they loved it and
the agent was like what are you doing
we're like wait a minute if they want to
do it and we like them like what
what does it matter if you don't want
them to have it so
so were you putting out multiple offers
for one role
to several actors and then waiting to
see oh it wasn't like no yeah
that's the reason it's so tricky in
terms of time is that you can you can
only offer a part to one person at a
time so you have an offer out and
let's say you have two months until
production
you're like that's a i can cast a movie
in two months that's plenty of time like
you audition people for a day you pick
someone you do so
suddenly that's like no time if you're
putting out offers because you have an
offer out for
a week you decide to let it sit another
week and then that person
says no and then you have another offer
out that person wants to do but there's
a scheduling conflict
and you try to work it around it but you
can't and then you're five weeks
done and you're three weeks from
production you don't have anyone casting
that part so we
definitely definitely came down to the
wire with like one
one roll we were you know yeah a
secondary roll
today on the movie we had someone who i
knew personally was going to do it
and then they couldn't because of a
scheduling conflict with a much bigger
project
and then we cast someone else who was
interested in doing it
who really liked the scenes but then
read the whole script and was like i
hate this script
i was like i'm not doing this movie and
then it was like three days before it
shot and we were out in the middle of
the desert and our castle directors were
finally like
hey we know you haven't seen this person
and you don't know anything about them
but
trust us they're gonna be amazing and we
trusted them and this actor was totally
amazing yeah
totally amazing yeah so then going back
to making the offer
are you writing like a letter of intent
like i mean how does this work and then
how long do you give that initial
correspondence before you circle back
and then i think it depends how bad you
want the actor
how realistic you think the possibility
is
and luckily we didn't i mean i think a
lot of people
we have a really wonderful producer who
really knows what she's doing so
between having casting directors that
were capable and do this all the time
and a producer like we didn't have to
deal with contracts we didn't have to
deal with offer sheets
you know the casting director sent those
out and even when it came down to
negotiating
between them and our great producer like
we we got to focus on the movie and we
didn't write we didn't like ever write a
love letter to anyone did we yeah we
totally did
we did oh yeah we were a letter stick at
that i wrote love letters
tell them to do the movie and i was like
ah dear friend
i love you yeah i would write letters to
people and talk about why i thought
they'd be great for the movie and
we did do that together really totally
blanking i don't have much of a mind
since my child was born
yeah we have a three month old baby
she's got baby brain we did we would we
would
i think that's really important to do
because especially if
well first you know our producer wrote
something that's coming out in a couple
days and the first thing she says in it
is
if you want to make a small movie have a
great script like don't go in with
anything but a great script it's so damn
hard
you have to have one and i think part of
a great script is
something that is great for actors like
write something that an actor wants to
do like it's so simple like give them
something different and interesting and
fun to do
and you know something that they can
that they feel will support their best
work
instead of make it harder for them to do
their best work
and then if you do that then if you
think of a certain actor and you're
like i think we both think of ourselves
as pretty good um
talent not telling us the wrong word but
we're good at seeing what people have in
them
we're good like scouts we're good
baseball scouts
and so we could say to people we've
watched your career and we think that
you have this thing in you
and in a number of cases in the movie we
were casting people against type like
even
jason ritter does a bunch of indie
movies and is so wonderful all the time
and he doesn't play the nicest guy in
our movie like he is
he's has a little bit of an edge to him
in a way that he doesn't always get to
play
and i think he he said he's like i wanna
one of the reasons i wanted to do this
was to get to do that and we knew that
he's a great actor and he could do it so
there was a lot of that for us and
and part of the way that you explain
that to people is to write them a letter
and say i know that you can do this and
and also i think especially with
first-time directors like us you can
give people a window into the way that
you work
remember don't you remember we did that
without the letters yeah we're kind of
like this is
our this is the way we work we are not
like
dust boot directors like i should sign
and sign and sign in
but germans are nice people too
i love germans um yeah we're much more
open and wanting to talk about things
and i think that that appealed to
actress